[Musique]
bonjour mackenzie wilson directrice des
opérations leur budget ou stationnaires
de la sonde spatiale intrépide est
stable elle se trouve à 342 km
d'altitude au dessus de mars
j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer que
tous les systèmes sont opérationnels
pour le lancement de la gamme pour qu'on
se prépare au lancement avec cinq heures
d'avant ce qu'il a autorisée
moi
[Applaudissements]
ce sera sans doute la fin d'émission
dirigée par l'homme une vie à 1.4
angénieux par les vagues qui sait de
quoi il est capable
il y a aucune activité humaine connue
sur ce site d'angers collision imminente
cibles verrouillées
feu
une aide en cas de menace potentielle je
suis autorisé 1
peach et tim roth c'est un artisan
automatique il est possible soit galère
tu veux dire surtout ne dit rien à
personne
ce tweak forcément commandé pour quelque
chose
[Musique]